but we have the story from
post-millennial this is Just Happening
Now breaking news Twitter temporarily
closes office building suspends employee
access on Thursday it was revealed that
Twitter had temporarily closed its
Office Buildings and suspended access
badges the officers officers are
expected to reopen Monday November 21st
giving Elon Musk and his team a chance
to sort things out sort what out
no details as given why they just
basically shut down we're hearing this
is because Elon Musk and his team are
terrified employees are going to
sabotage the company also they're still
trying to figure out which Twitter
workers they need to cut access for
shift report that employees were being
told to continue to comply with company
policy by refraining from discussing
confidential company information on
social media with the press or elsewhere
it's interesting Elon Musk effectively
performed a hostile takeover of a woke
institution yes these these people are
whiny baby children and are imploding
and this is what happens when you do
it's it's it's it's it's fascinating
it's imagine like you're on the high
seas and you board the enemy ship
they're not just going to be like well I
guess we work for you now well it was
like this comical employment where
you're getting insane amounts of money
you're you know riding a scooter through
the office it's just this insane job
that you could have and now they don't
know what to do there's no like it's not
even realistic I mean that's what our
headquarters is basically like a daycare
have you seen the video in the day in
the life of a Twitter employee and they
have meditation rooms and game rooms and
lattes and whatever wine bars yeah on a
roof yeah yeah yes they're these little
latte liberals who are like basically
working in a giant daycare and they're
go they have they're going online and
complaining about their boss and then
being like why did I get fired he's this
big evil man but he wouldn't have done
anything if they weren't complaining
about him publicly yeah Patrick Bateman
in the 80s would seem like a harder
worker than anybody on Twitter maybe
what needs to happen is Elon just buy
all the companies
and then I'll just crumble oh that would
be great grab Facebook
I would love it I would like it yeah on
its own it's falling apart yeah they are
doing it great they just did a massive
layoff too didn't they what was it 10
000 employees they're laying off yeah
but
Zuckerberg was right to try something
new with meta yeah AR stuff because
Facebook itself as a company is aging
out of existence yep that's it they're
going AOL that's what everyone thought
was gonna happen good good riddance get
out of here I'm sick of your crap yeah
but Tick Tock is replacing them yeah but
at the same time okay fine but but that
Empire was absolutely evil with how they
worked and orchestrated larger psyopsis
against the American people how they
censored people I I think we are seeing
a digital uh transition I I think what
we're seeing at Twitter is some kind of
Civil War happening inside of that
company obviously I would not want to be
at the helm of being in charge of
thousands of woke employees project
Veritas did an undercover video one of
the employees at Twitter said that they
worked four hours a week okay imagine
having to deal with those kind of
entitled individuals that just want to
be at a wine bar the whole time it it
would be extremely difficult to get
anything done here I I'm still waiting
for Elon Musk to bring people back act
that were banned but I could see a lot
of internal battles a lot of internal
fights happening right now just
basically on that one particular issue
the unbannings I think this is
personally just from my own speculation
what this is all about and there's
probably some people at the at the
company saying I'll uh I will jeopardize
this I will expose this I will say this
I will destroy this company I will tell
people how many Bots are on this company
if uh you allow Donald Trump to be on
this platform or project Veritas or all
the other dozens of individuals or
Babylon b or everyone else that that
should have not been banned do it the
the issue is the advertisers though he's
really struggling with trying not to
bankrupt this company by you know
throwing all the advertisers to the wind
I think that's why he was so quick to
try the Twitter blue stuff too which
obviously was rolled out a little too
quickly
um I think he knew that yeah he did but
um so I think that's why we're not
seeing a lot of these unbannings yet is
because he's trying to really grapple
with him while he's getting rid of some
of the staff as he needs it on the right
track to tell advertisers hey this is
you know where we need to go this is
probably why he didn't want to buy it he
tried backing out he saw the data and
then realized that the reason Twitter is
doing this is because of Advertiser
pressure and that if he goes in and
makes these changes then the advertisers
drop there's no money and the company's
gone and so they were like good luck
buddy but that's why as soon as he comes
in like you said Twitter blue right now
everyone sign up or government pressure
I already did
you signed up yeah I did but he needs to
implement a class structure there
because I bought Twitter blue and my
check mark my check mark used to saying
this person's verified because she's
really cool and super important and now
it says it's because I pay for Twitter
Flume yeah it's fine everybody can know
Elon says that too he made he made a
mistake with that one because right now
he he is saying he's going to remove
Legacy Badges and they're all they're
going to drop off the next couple of
months fine but bro if you're if you're
if you're going around saying like you
can have the limited edition first
edition badge or the like like the
reprint I don't want to reprint no no
like why am I going to pay for that okay
and Tim you know the dimensions are
really bad Luke you know that it's
really hard for us to sort things not to
be in elitist Twitter prick but it's
really bad you know I can't see you
can't see anything that's notable
there's so many clear retention it's
really I only talk to important people
so let me tell you it's hard to you know
when you use it for business too it's
hard to sort through Dimensions now it's
going to my my mobile app is the Twitter
Beta app which I've not updated
yes and um my mentions are the same as
they've always been
anyone who bought Twitter blue does not
appear verified on this app really yeah
so I I noticed because we got Twitter
blue for timcast news because I was like
I want the news organization to have a
verification badge on it and so I logged
on my phone and there's no badge and I
was like what I was like what am I what
am I paying for and then I looked online
and it was there and I was like huh then
everyone started saying mentions were
busted and I pulled up my phone and
looked and I'm like the only people in
my mentions are Legacy verified people
and so uh so you're not updating I'm not
updating again
he's an elitist prick too well so he's
earned it but this is interesting
I already have a mentioned sections a
section for everyone if you tweet at me
and you're talking at me and you have
and you you have a standard count that's
fine the verification tab doesn't
doesn't need to be the the elites or
anything like that but it does create a
space where the people who are
interacting with me are working for some
company or something like that right so
then it's typically what typically what
I see is journalists talking about stuff
or people I know and I've worked with
talking about stuff
now with the Twitter blue verification
I'm hearing people say like they lost
that feed of their colleagues yep so
he's got to figure out filters for this
stuff yeah but I again I think he rolled
it out so quickly that because he just
wanted to give a cushion to everything
that's going on with the advertisers but
I don't really think there's a way
around that
um he's just got to let go that the
advertisers they're not going to care if
he lets these people back on the
platform they're the advertisers are
gone well what I don't like is that he
created the second verification
the official tag now like wow dude so
it's confusing and weird and right and
why does the corporate media right it
just and how so how do I get it for Tim
cast news huh I want you know I want to
be double verified what do I got to do
huh we are changing with Johnson yeah
huh how are we gonna make sure he gets
into office with this kind of
shenanigans I know you know what's going
on here not to mention two with a lot of
the people though that the age that
we're working for them the fact that
that's kind of the mentality of that
group does he is there a way that he can
actually control his employees I mean
how do you really know I mean aren't
they kind of old against him mine is a
small percentage you know I'll I'll tell
you that I don't know
the challenge is is best described this
way if you have a storefront in any City
and uh it's not on here and you put a
sign in the window that says you support
Trump in the middle of the night a guy
puts on a mask and throws a brick
through your window causing you
thousands of dollars in Damages and
potentially shutting your store down for
the day you call the police what are the
police going to tell you oh
you have insurance yeah they said well
what are we supposed to do about it you
say I don't know stop the guy how I got
video footage of him okay it's a guy in
a hoodie what do you want us to do
forensic analysis CSI dust for Prince
track every survey it's not going to
happen
so Elon Musk knows this
if someone does sabotage the company
sure he can look in the logs but I I
would guarantee you
that if one of his employees committed a
felony against him law enforcement would
do nothing about it no it's probably
true
establishment and he would have to use
his own people to actually press charges
against him and go that route that would
never it'll never happen you don't think
so absolutely not if uh if it was the
other way around yeah hands down oh of
course if Twitter was owned by You Know
Jack Dorsey and Vijaya got it at the
helmet it was pro-democrat like it had
been for years oh for sure and an
employee sabotaged it because they were
tied to the political bias they'd be
locked up in 10 seconds oh I agree and
and I'm not saying this based on like
perceived political bias I'm saying it
based on actually looking at how law
enforcements and operating in this
country and uh personal experience
if if someone commits a very serious
federal crime it will not it just
doesn't happen like
I've talked to like swatting is a really
great example I was just going to bring
that up but I don't know if we were
supposed to go right exactly I was going
to say is that specifically what you
were mentioning partly yeah but um we
have evidence
and so you know I go we've talked to
multiple law enforcement agencies and
they're just like guy you have you have
you you have armed guards you're fine
and then I'm like dude this is like gone
on too much they're committing crimes
they're like don't care sorry have a
nice day it's nothing it's been a year
yeah they're using your people to commit
crimes and you don't care
but but the issue is now that we are
paying for it right now that we pay for
uh armed guards and things like that
they're like oh so we don't got to worry
about anymore right
so so what
and I'm like okay they don't care in
general though because I know I had a
really bad stalker Lauren Southern and I
had the same stalker I stopped it was it
was very you're here I know well
it was really bad and I remember you
know it got escalated up to the FBI and
I had the FBI he was the head of the
Cyber crimes Division and he calls me
and I said yeah a lot of this stuff is
happening on Twitter the guys made like
300 plus YouTube videos about me
um you know what the guy at the FBI the
head of the cyber crime division you
know what he told me he said have you
tried calling Twitter I said start with
alter perspective you think I can call
Twitter you shouldn't be headed cyber
crimes unit seriously to call Twitter
about a stalker a very serious stalker I
had the FBI that's amazing well you know
if there's a if there's a trap if
there's a traffic violation the cops are
there and it generates revenue for the
state but uh your life's in danger they
don't give a damn that's that's usually
the protocol of what's Happening Here
and it's very interesting to see what's
happening because we have U.S senators
right now calling for the FTC to
investigate Twitter and Elon Musk as we
have the whole FTX scandal with clients
losing billions of dollars and then they
don't care about that they're they're
not really doing anything around that
issue the FBI is giving a warning to the
guy saying hey we probably will be
investigating you this is your time to
leave and Escape right now literally
giving away warning it's almost like
they laundered 40 million dollars for
the Democrats well that's what it looks
like absolutely the crazy thing about
FTX is it seems like what they were
trying to do what this guy Bank manfreda
sang is hey we didn't do anything on
tour with your money we didn't gamble it
we we loaned it to Alameda yeah and then
Alameda does Investments and they make
investments their money they weren't
gambling that's what their company does
and the money's lost yep my question
where was the money invested who
benefited because think about the the
chain right here Democrats 11 billion
people
11 oh I'm sorry 11 billion dollars
obviously not a billion people 11
billion dollars in American money was
was in FTX gone now because it's
transferred to Alameda Alameda did
something with that money
they didn't give 11 billion dollars to
Democrats
and why does it stop there why where why
is the media just stopping here let's
figure out where Alameda put that money
because I'm willing to bet there's
there's more co-conspirators
so they basically are playing this game
of look I'm just a company that that
receipt that invests in uh this that or
otherwise and Alameda came to me and
said they wanted to invest don't look at
me the money's mine now it's clean how
many steps until they actually take that
money and doesn't come back
yeah it's like the cartel
essentially well it is it's the same
thing it's money laundering I mean it's
just it's so what do you do with cocaine
it's what you do with anything else 40
million of it went to Democrats yes 40
million went to democrats for uh Ballard
harvesting yeah largely
the U.S taxpayer dollars essentially
yeah and then you have these huge names
that had a huge amount of money in you
know involved in it so it's out there
it's completely public I think there's
also breaking news right now of the
local government in the Bahamas actually
taking control of the remaining FTX
assets uh right now in the making of
this video so they also invested a lot
of money in alleged Tech startups in
allegedly global warming and also
fighting the next pandemic where that
money went I think you know we should be
asking a lot of very serious questions
because people were defrauded people
lost their money that money of course
was was sent to politicians not just
Democrats also you know GOP causes and
Republican candidates as well and
they're super Pacs so we have to
understand you know protection money
goes both ways how will it protect them
what's going to happen next is going to
be really really interesting and
fascinating to see how rotten and
corrupted the entire system is thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time